その梵天が頭が悪くて
お釈迦様にチャレンジして
お釈迦様もまあそのチャレンジを受けて
まあ競争して まあ負けてしまったと
梵天が あのバカっていうのは
このパーリ辞書を引くと
あの 何といいますか しらさぎ
しらさぎ しらさぎというんですか？あの鳥
鳥は頭が悪いと思っているでしょうかね
それは第一禅定のこと
それで第二禅定にも三段階がありまして
あの 弱く修行するとパリッタ・スブという梵天に生まれるし
中ぐらいで修行するとアッパマーナ・スブというところに生まれるし
力強く修行するとスブキッナというところに生まれるんですね
この無量光天と八光天
ちょっと間違えた この第二禅定と第三禅定は一緒に数えているんですね
だから第二と第三は小さく修行するとパリッタ・スブ
パリッタ・アブ まあ光ですね
中ぐらいの修行するとアッパマーナ
アッパマーナ・アブ 無量光
強く修行すると八光天という名前ですね
そこで第四禅定の場合は三次元ありまして
一番目はパリッタ・スブ
少浄光天 中の場合は無量浄光天と
強く修行すれば遍浄光天と書いてあるんですね
この まあそういう名前言うしか
まあなかなかどういうことかちょっとわかりにくいんですね
その梵天の状態 そういうのはなんかすごいエネルギーなんですね
だからすごいこの体があるというよりは
このものすごいこのエネルギー
基本的なエネルギーだけでできている体なんですね
ですから光というふうに書いてる
だから体自体は光でできていると
光といえばこの素粒子なんですね
ですからまあ素粒子だけでできてあって
この我々みたいなものすごい複雑な
あの 構想が体にできてないんですね
ですから だから複雑な体を持ってるんだから早く壊れちゃうんですね
早く体腐っちゃうんですね
もし我々の体はこの植物みたいなものでできてるんだったら
それほど複雑じゃないんですけどね
それでも複雑ですけどね
もっと長生きできるかもしれませんだけどね
で まあ人間の体にも DNA であろうか
まあまあアミノ酸であろうか
まああんまりに複雑で
ものすごい大きいんですね
一つのポイント ユニットはね
ですからちょっとしたことで壊れちゃうんです
ですから この 例えば幻想みたいなもので出来たっちゃったら
そういうものはかなり長い間生きていられるし
で 梵天の場合はやっぱりまあ素粒子みたいなもので
光とかね そういうふうな
このもっときめ細かいエネルギーの塊であって
ですから もうものすごい大きいんですね
大きさも 大きいんだからといって
例えばどこまででも広げることはできるし
そういうわけで我々には見えないんですね
見ることもできない 五番目の禅定の場合は
一つですね 梵天は ヴィーハッパラという高果天
で 五番目の禅定は二種類ありまして
あの心を止まる瞑想もありますね
心を止まる瞑想をしたら
あのアサンギサッタというところに生まれるんですね
無想無情天に生じると
それからこの修行して悟った人々
特にこの不還果という状態に悟った人々は
このまだ阿羅漢になってないんですね
最終悟りを得ていない
第三番目まで悟っていると
そういう人々は必ずしも梵天に生まれるんです
天国には生まれません
不還果の人々は 一来果とかね
預流果とかね 天国には生まれます
人間にも戻れます 不還果は天国にも生まれません
ですから梵天に生まれるんです
だから あの特別どこに生まれるかということは決まってないんですが
あの こちらはこのスッダーワーサ
上境天という風にまあ名前をつけてるんですね
まあおそらくこの第一禅定から第四禅定までの梵天どこかにいるでしょうと思いますけど
自分が得た禅定によってもうどこかにいるだろうと思いますけど
でも不還果だから格が違うんですね
落ちることはないんです
梵天に生まれ変わっても
この自分の徳が終わったら死ななくちゃいけないんですね
梵天でも死ぬことは死ぬんだから
それで死んでから他のどこかに生まれ変わるんです
輪廻転生するんです 不還果は輪廻転生はしない
ですから あの 何と言いますか
永住権みたいなもんなんですね
梵天にいても ですから
他の梵天と比べるとものすごい立場が違うんです
他の梵天が自分の禅定の力
結果が終わると どんどん力が弱くなってきて
そこでカルマが消えると
すぐ梵天もそこで死んでしまっちゃうんですね
その死んでしまう恐れが
この不還果の人々にはないんです
ただそれだけでもかなり差がありますからね
だから我々にとっては梵天の寿命は長いんだけど
梵天にとってはそんな長く感じませんだからね
何億年いると言ったっても
そちらはみんな何億年もいるんだから
まあそんなにね 長く感じるわけじゃないし
ですから このそちらではまあ
他の梵天が死んでいっちゃう
死んで死んで消えていっちゃうし
その不還果の梵天は別に死ぬっていうことはないと
ただずっとそこにいて
そこで悟ると 完全に悟り開いて
もう解脱 涅槃に入るんですね
そういうことで この あの
不還果の人々が生まれる場所別にないと私は思いますけど
その不還果の梵天たちだけまとめて
この浄光天と名前をつけてるんです
そこでこの無色界 無色界
次の禅定 あの百六十二ページ
ここまで説明しましたけど
前はね 今日は百六十二からなんですけど
無色界までは説明しましたけど
まあ無色界っていうのは
この色界の第四禅定まで終わった人々が
この心だけの修行してね
それすごい難しい修行なんですけど
高い禅定四つ作るんですね
その高い禅定を四つ作る
で その禅定を四つ作った人々は
それなりの四つの場所に生まれ変わるんです
それはそれだけのこと
いわゆるアーカーサーナンチャーヤタナという
あの空無辺禅定 作った人々は空無辺という梵天に生まれる
梵天もその同じ名前なんですね
アーカーサーナンチャーヤタナ・ブラフマタラというんですね
空無辺という梵天次元に生まれると
色無辺禅定 二番目 色無辺禅定という色無辺禅定を作った人が色無辺禅定の梵天に生まれると
アーキンチャンニャーヤタナって何でしたっけ？日本語で
無生有生禅定ですね だから無生有生禅定作った人はその次元に行くし
非想非非想浄の禅定を作った人がその次元に生まれるんですね
そちらだけはこの次元の差がないんです
大体同じなんです あの
例えば色 あの空無辺禅定を作ったら
この空無辺禅定の あの
小中大はないんです ですから
そこだけは一応平等なんですけど
でも体はないんですね
全く体はない 体っていうのは物質的なものは何もない
心だけ 心だけだから もう
普通の禅定でコンタクトを取ることはできないんです
じゃあ心で心でコンタクトできるんじゃないかなと思いますけど
そこでちょっとこの あの
実践的なプラクティカルな立場でちょっと問題があるんですね
で 高次元とコンタクトを取る場合は
人間がコンタクト取るんですね
人間の心はやっぱり物質がないと機能しないんですね
ですから この高次元的な知恵
超能力を得たい人が第四禅定まで禅定を作らなくちゃいけない
第四禅定でこのウペッカーシャーと
あの統一性ですか その二つしか心にないんです
いわゆる心には何の感情もない
ただ集中力のみ その心を作ってからいろいろまあ違う能力つけることはできるんです
でもそれは色界なんですね
いわゆるこのただ集中力だけあるのは
まあそれ物質に依存してその集中力できてるんですね
そういうわけだから この色界の梵天とは次元が低いんです
次元が低いんだから 次元の高いあの無色界とはコンタクトできないんです
そこで人間が じゃあ無色界の禅定も作ったとする
そうするとコンタクト不可能になる
心は物質と関係なくなっちゃったんだから
心自体は他の対象は受けないんです
何も 心は一方走行で動いてるだけ
他の影響は受けないんです
他の影響を受けないと
他のものはあるかないかはもう認識できないんです
だから私の 私は私の心であの梵天
あるいは神々を見ているんだと
神々と話してるんだというならば
私の心が影響を受けてるんですね
[咳払い]神々の声を聞いている
聞いて認識している だから神々の声を聞いて認識するためには
私は私の心はそこのレベルまで
第四禅定まで成長しているんですね
第四禅定で物質に依存しているんです
その時でも 色界だから
それで高次元とコンタクトできるんです
もし私の心はこの色界乗り越えて無色界の禅定に入ったら
もう物質に依存していない
それで他の影響は受けない状態になっているんです
心は一人勝手に行動しているだけで
外の影響はまるっきり受けられない状態まで育てられているんです
そうすると 無色界の次元には上ったことは上ったんだけど
他の無色界の生命とコンタクトすることも不可能なんです
それだけじゃなくて 他の低次元の人々ともコンタクト取るのは不可能なんです
ですから この超能力を仏教で使っているのは神通という言葉ですから
神通力の場合は第四禅定で神通力を作るんです
第四禅定とアビダルマの第五番目の禅定は同じものなんです
ですから 第四禅定で神通力作るんだから
神通力付きにももうリミットというものはやっぱりあるんですね
[咳払い]無色界の禅定を作ったらもう何もできない
人がこの 人が例えば瞑想して第四禅定を作ると
大体呼吸も止まれるぐらいなんですね
大 もう無色界に入っちゃうと
ほとんど体の機能を停止するんです
で 体と心は全く別々なものになってしまっちゃうんですね
体はそれなりに機械としてゆっくりと維持して動くんだけど
あのー 心の影響はないんです
今我々の体っていうのはずっと心の影響で生きているんですね
ですから この [咳払い]瞑想すればするほど
体が心の影響を受けることはどんどん少なくなっちゃうんですね
で 無色界になっちゃうと
もうほとんど影響を受けない状態になってしまっちゃう
そうすると 無色界の人
無色界の禅定ある人にとっては
まあ神通力とかアーダートとか
そういう何も関係なくなっちゃうんです
そういう光見えるとか
音を聞こえるとか 超次元の音を聞こえるとかね
そういうのはもう色界の瞑想の世界なんです
そこでこの仏教で言ってる神通力
あるいは現代語で言えば
そういういわゆる超能力というものは
いい加減なものではないんです
きちんとこの修行して育てたもので
ちゃんと管理されているものなんですね
ですから そちらから得られる知識知恵っていうのはしっかりしたもので
中途半端なものではないんです
たまたま誰が幽霊見たとかね
そういうのは仏教では超能力の世界にはเข้าへ
ま 入れません 本人にはコントロールできませんからね
で 時々はいるんです このこのカルマの結果としてね
なんかちょっと ちょっとした違うことできるという人々もあり得るんですけど
でもその人々には何のコントロールもできない
自分のその持っている能力の
それでその能力を育てることもできないんです
壊すことはできますけど
欲に溺れたり 怒りに溺れたりすると
その能力 生まれつき付いてる能力あるならば
それは消えちゃうんですけど
育てることは不可能なんです
あの 仏教で言ってる神通っていうのはそういうものではなくて
きちんとしたプロセスがあって
それによって育てたものであるし
本人には綺麗にコントロールできるんです
ですから たまたま幽霊見たではなくて
もう餓鬼道のものを見たければ
あ まあここら辺にいる餓鬼道を見ますと言って
もうチャンネルを合わせるだけなんですね
それでそのものが見えると
誰かの声聞きたければ
あ こういうこういう声を聞き
これから聞きますと言って
自分の心のチャネルを瞑想して
それで合わせちゃう 合わせたらそれをちゃんと聞こえ
聞こえたりする それもこの目連尊者みたいに
このむちゃくちゃ修行しちゃうと
ものすごい力強く修行すると
この超能力とかなんとかというものをね
まあ一般的にももうコントロールなしにも見えたりはします
それはかえってすごい迷惑みたいなもんなんですけどね
かなり落ち着いていないとね
余計なこと見えたり聞こえたりしちゃうとね
まあ結構ややこしくて大変なんですけどね
でも禅定に入ってみるのは別にややこしいものでも何でもないんですね
必要なものだけ見ると
これはまあ 図書館に行って
あのカタログを見て 自分に必要な本を選ぶというふうなものなんですね
図書館ですから もう何千万冊も本はあるんですね
ありとあらゆる分野に分けていろんな本がある
で そこで ただ何もコントロールしていない人は
図書館に行ったら驚くかもしれません 「
すごい本がありますね」とかね 「
あ こういう本もあります
こういう本もあります
目に映る本があります
あります」って言うだけであって
じゃあその人に頼んで 「
じゃあなんとかの本を探してください」って言ったら
決して探せません 図書館のこと知らない人が図書館のね
あの倉庫に入ってしまったら 「
あ すごい本があるもんですね」とかね
手に 目の前にある 「あ
こんなすごい本ですね」と驚くかもしれません
で その人に私は英語の文法をちょっと勉強したいんだけど
ですからこの あの 英語の文法に関係ある
あの 一般の人に読めるぐらいの本一冊探してくださいと言ったら
まるっきりできない 全くできない
迷子になるだけ で コントロールした能力ある人は
図書館に入ってびっくりするということじゃなくて
あ 英語だったら 例えばデビのデシマルシステムだったら
これ四百九 四百九十三ぐらいに入ってるんですね
その番号あるところに行って
あ そこで一般人の向けだったら
もうそこまた九十三点四一三五とかね
そういう番号ついてるんですからね
その番号の本を引っ張れば
あ この本ですよ すぐわかるんですね
ですから この図書館の
何と言いますか この整理学で何と言ってもわかりませんだけど
このそのシステムを知っている人は
もうコントロールした能力を持っている人は決して図書館に迷子にはなりません
で まあ超能力っていうのも大体そういうもののようなものであってね
で 仏教で認めている 説明している人相っていうのは
そういう風にちゃんとコントロールしている能力なんです
そういう能力がついてる人に
もうかなり修行が進んでいる人にとっては
瞑想していない時でも
ちらちらといろんなものは見えたり
目に映ったり 心に映ったりする可能性はありますけどね
そういうストーリーは結構あの
あのサミットにかというところには記録しているんです
じゃあ 今まで説明したのは全部前に説明しましたけど
まあ次に百六十二のチュティパティサンディッカラナ
死と決勝の順ですかね
これすごい簡単です アーユッキャーエナ
カッマッキャーエナ ウベヤッキャーエナ
ウパッチェーデカ カッムナーティ
カッムナーチェーティ
チャトゥダー マラナ ウッパッティ
ナーマ で あの大体この死ぬことを説明していますけど
同時に生まれることも言うんですね
人は死んだらすぐ生まれると
それはもう確実なんですね
この死ぬということと決勝ということはもうつなげているんです
この死ぬということは大変なすごいことやという
とんでもないことだと思っているのは一般の人々だけなんです
アビダーマの立場からはもう大したことないんです
死ぬっていうことは ただ
心はいつでも消えるんですね
瞬間瞬間 心は死んで新しい心が生まれる
それは光より十七倍の速さで心が生まれて死ぬ
死 死んでは生まれる 死んでは生まれる
死んでは生まれる だから心というのはほんの瞬間しか
一刹那しか寿命はないんです
ですから この時間の一番短い単位は心刹那なんですね
心の一刹那 心一つ生まれて死ぬ時間は一刹那と
と数えているんですね
ですから 心の寿命というのは一刹那なんですね
そういうわけで 我々にとってはもう心はあまり早くこの
死んでいくんだからわからないだけなんですね
なぜ我々わからないかというと
この同じ体で心が生まれては死ぬ
生まれては死ぬ 生まれては死ぬ
ですから 同じ体の中でその出来事が起きているんだから
死んでないんだと 私はずっと田中でも 80歳までいるんだと勘違いしているだけなんですね
でも体も変化はしているんだけど
その変化はまた認めない
心はみるみる限り変化するんだけど認めない
だから認めないのは無知だからね
変化を認めないことは
だからそれはあんまり大したことないんですね
人は頭が悪いんだから
その人の言うことを信じなくちゃいけないというのは全く屁理屈でしょうし
例えば 我々の心は瞬間瞬間変化するんだということが
人はわかっているはずなんですね
急に怒ったりする 急に笑ったりする
急に落ち込んだりする
急に楽しがったりする
いろんな感情みるみるうちに変わるでしょうし
で そういう風にずっと
我々の心が変わっていくし
体も変わっていくし お腹がすいたら体が違う
喉が渇いたら体が違う
そこで喉が渇いたところに何か飲んだところで
またすぐ体が変わってしまっちゃう
そういうふうに体も変わっていく
でも無知な人がそれを認めない
全部私ですよと もう何の証拠なしに言葉でラベリングして
私という言葉に引かれて同じものだと
心も変化しているんだけど
無知な人はその変化は認めない
そこで無知な人は人の瞬間の死を認めないんですね
私は 80 80 年間生きてきましたとかね
65 年間生きてきましたとかのいろんなことを言うんですね
それこそ事実ですよとかね
それでその人々が確固たる事実を認めない
確固たる事実を認めないのは無知な行動でありますし
無知な人だからね 例えばこの机の上に缶一つありますよというのは
誰にでも見える事実なんですね
もし私がいえ ここには缶はないんだと言うならば
私は愚か者なんですね
見える 触れる 触れる感を否定しているんだからね
ですから この見える体験できる無常を認めないのは無知な人々の行動なんです
ですから その人々が死ぬということは
大変大胆な行動として見ているんです
その人々は人が死んだらどこに生まれるでしょうとかね
おそらく生まれないでしょうとかね
いろんなことを言う 我々一般人もその無知な人言うことは正しいと
事実否定する人が正しいと
事実を認める人は間違っていると平気で言うんです
その屁理屈なんですね
ですから 理屈だけ純粋に言うと
あの人は事実否定している
あの人は認めるべきものは認めないで否定している
だからその人を信じましょうと
ということなんですね
それもあまりにもおかしいんです
それで私は言いたいのは
我々は瞬間瞬間死んでいるんです
人というのは心があるんだから
人であるならば その心が死んだということ
その人が死んだということなんです
また同じ機械の中で その代わりに新しい心が生まれる
で そこまたその心が死ぬ
また新しい心が生まれる
同じ入れ物機械の中に
それで機械自体も心ほど早くないんだけど
ゆっくりと変化していく
それは一般の世界では認めていない
人は生まれてからずっと生きていて
後で死ぬんだと言うんですね
その後で死ぬんだという概念が
仏教では世俗帯 一般の人々の立場の真理だと
でも正義体ではないんだと
本当の事実ではない 一般人から見れば死ですよと
というこの我々死んだという概念が
仏教でいえばそれは世俗帯なんですね
死はいつでもあるもので
いつでも死ななきゃ新しいものを生まれないんですね
だから我々は勉強すると新しい知識が生まれるでしょうに
それには前の心が死ななきゃ
生まれるわけじゃないんです
体が死ななければいくら運動したって健康的にならないんですね
弱い体の人が運動すると
その弱い体がじわじわと死んでいって
強い体が出来上がっちゃうんです
だから死がなければもう何も成り立たなくなっちゃうんですね
その瞬間の死っていうのは一番大事なことです
そういうわけで この世俗体で世論として見る死も
仏教では死と決勝というつ繋げて喋っているんです
別にこの科学的な証拠を出して
人が死んだら生まれ変わりますよということは仏教ではやりません
なぜならば それは非科学的なんですね
人は死んだらって その人が死んだらという言葉自体が間違っているんです
なぜならばずっと死んでいるんだから
ずっと死ぬと生まれるんだから
それだったら世俗的に死ぬ瞬間でも
また生まれるということは
まあ何のことなく当たり前のことなんです
そういうわけで この瞬間の死を理解する人は
この物体の死を死後も心は続くんだということは
もういとも簡単に理解できるんです
で 本当のことを言うと
この死ぬ人が自分が死ぬということはほとんどわからないんです
一応一ヶ月間前とかね
三ヶ月間前とかはわかるんですね
私はもうこの体はそろそろ終わるだと
もう維持できないんだと
ものすごく心でわかってるんですね
大体三ヶ月間ぐらいになってくると
その時も心がベストに行動し始めちゃうんですね
体がボロボロだから 体の中に心になかなか行動できないんですね
で 体のいろんな次元があるんですね
この目に見えるこの物体だけではなくて
このまた素粒子でできている
もうもうまたすごい大きい体が持ってるんだからね
例えば私の体には 何て言いますか
物体ですから この体にも引力があるんですね
その引力で周りのいろんな素粒子を引っ張ってるんです
ですから 私が持っている引力によって
まあかなり大きいスケールで違う体があるんです
浮いてるんです それはずっと
そこでもう体と心のエネルギーが強く弱くなっちゃうと
そのエネルギーの場が小さくなっちゃうし
強くなってくるとどんどんエネルギーの場が大きくなっちゃうっていうのは
そういう風にこの物体の体のいろんな変化があるし
それでこの 強い物体はね
弱くなってボロボロ状態になっちゃうと
心がもう もうこのそれを死の物質に入ったりとかね
まあ行動したりすると
まあ本人が大体はわかっているんですね
まあそろそろ体が止まるんだと
それに怖くなったりすると
また心のエネルギーが悪くなっちゃうし
で 欲が出てきて  じゃあ財産は残していかなくちゃいけないんだとかね
で ああだこう まあ子供たちは残して死ぬわけにいけないとか
ああだこうだ思っちゃうと
心がずっと汚れてしまって
またそれなりにエネルギーフィールドですか
エネルギーの場がもう変化しちゃうんですね
で 死ぬ時はもうざっとわからないんです
死んだっていうことさえも
本人はもう気が付いてないんです
ただもう自分の朦朧状態になっちゃいますからね
体と関係なく心は動いていて
そのままもう動いてしまっちゃうんです
そこでこの体に心動いていたのに
私たちから見れば あ 死んだと
と見えるだけで 本人の立場から見れば全然もう何のこともないんです
ただつなげていくだけなんです
だから死ぬのは怖いのは
まあ死なない人々なんですけど
死ぬ本人にとってはあまり怖い現象でもないんです
で 死ぬ前は怖いんですね
みんな死なないんだとか思ってるんだから
死ということはすごい怖い現象なんです
死ぬ瞬間ではもう怖いとかあるとか考えてる暇がないんです
すぐ次の次元に行ってしまっちゃう
で その次元がこの前の今までの生きてきた人生とかね
今までの あるいは最近の生き方とかね
あるいはその瞬間で心はどういうふうに変化したかということによって
この流れがすぐ消えて変わってしまっちゃう
心っていうのはすぐ変化するんだから
ものすごいニコニコ笑っていても
すぐ泣き出すという可能性はいつでもあるんです
そういうわけだから 一般の人に心を育ててない人にとっては
死後はどこに生まれるかということは決めることは不可能なんですね
心は育ててないと 私は必ずしも極楽道に行くぞとかね
それさえもすごい邪見なんですね
お釈迦様がおっしゃったのは
もしある人が聞いたんですね
私は死んだら天国に行きたい
生まれ変わりたいんだと
教えてください 言ったら
それだったらもう長い間
こうこういうことをしなくちゃいけないんだと
やっぱり修行法を教えたんですね
長い間 この特に戒律を守ることと
いろいろ徳を積むことと
お布施したりとかね それから希望すること
心で強く希望すること
私はこういう風なこの戒律を守って
人を助けてあげたりして
お布施をしたりして 私は天国に
死んでから天国に生まれ変わりますよという概念をずっと持ち続けること
そうすると一体になっちゃうんです
その概念が それで死ぬ時になってくると
ああ死ぬ ああそろそろ死ぬ
ああ今までずっと私は天国に行きたがっていたんだという気持ちが生まれてくるんですね
それで自分の意志が天界に行ってしまって
そうでないと行かないんです
難しいことではないんだけどね
天国ぐらいに行くということはそんな難しいことじゃないんですけどね
で まあ常にまあ喜びの心とね
まあ清らかというかね
まあ自分なりにこの人間らしく納得して生きてきたんだと
というこの充実感とかね
納得という気持ちがあったりしてね
もう後悔はない心とかね
あんまりまあ後悔することはないんだと
で それなりによく頑張って生きてきたんだというぐらいの清らかさあれば
まあ大体天国には行けるんですね
で わからないんだからしょうがないやと思う人々はどこに行くかわからないんです
やっぱりいいところに生まれる
生まれ変わるためにも欲が必要なんで
それなりの だからどうしても輪廻転生は欲
渇愛でやるものだからね
で 渇愛ない人がね 私は死後のことを考えてないんだと
どこに生まれなくても同じことだと
変化はよくないんだと
とにかく解脱をしたいんだと
思ってる人が だからといって涅槃に入るわけじゃないんです
気持ちだけやるんだから涅槃っていうことはないんだからね
やっぱり悟らなくちゃいけないんですけどね
そういう人々はどうなるんですかと
天国に あなた天国に行きたいんですか？と
別にという気持ちでしょうし
じゃあ梵天？別にどこ行ったって同じことだからと
私はずっと頑張ったのは解脱を得たいと頑張ったん